The Joe Rogan Experience people thought
that Trump nft thing was fake for three
days oh my gosh no he's really jacked
like that have you watched that
commercial yet bro how crazy is he how
crazy
your favorite President better than
Washington better than Lincoln play that
because it's so ridiculous and this is
like a big announcement sold out and
it's sold out he's holding us like the
Statue of Liberty torch in one of the
pictures that makes me so sad
those trumpers man they [ __ ] love him
like he's the Dallas Cowboys you know
it's like they're just loyal to the team
it's like us against them that's what
they've you know there's a certain type
of person in this country that feels
unrepresented you know that is so funny
though here's the website I'm trying to
get to the official wow just look at the
whoever look at this look at this chest
jacked ridiculous play it I can't
believe this is real this is real
Trump Towers hello everyone this is
Donald Trump hopefully your favorite
President of all time better than
Lincoln better than Washington with an
important announcement to make I'm doing
my first official Donald J Trump nft
collection right here and right now
they're called Trump digital trading
cards these cards feature some of the
really incredible artwork pertaining to
my life and my career it's been very
exciting you can collect your Trump
digital cards just like a baseball card
or other Collectibles here's one of the
best parts each card comes with an
automatic chance to win amazing prizes
like dinner with me I don't know if
that's an amazing prize but it's what we
have we're golf with you and a group of
your friends at one of my beautiful golf
courses and they are beautiful I'm also
doing Zoom calls a one-on-one meeting
autographing memorabilia and so much
more we're doing a lot my official Trump
digital trading cards are 99 dollars
which doesn't sound like very much for
what you're getting buy one and you will
join a very exclusive Community it's my
community and I think it's something
you're going to like and you're going to
like it a lot they also make perfect
gifts so you can buy them with your
credit card or crypto all you need is an
email address go to
collecttrumpcards.com okay okay I get it
if you bought 45 of them you got invited
to dinner just imagine just imagine
saying that you bought 45 of them that's
all it takes to go to dinner with them
well you just got to know Kanye Max was
a hundred you could buy forty five
thousand dollars yep or no 4 500. oh man
dinner yeah I would have done that it
was like it wasn't a personal dinner it
was a big like celebration I don't know
yeah he's a table behind a little
bulletproof glass right I'm the best
your favorite dinner guest of all time
no it's just like an apple piece
you buy 45 you're guaranteed a ticket to
dinner with the president oh my God
you're guaranteed a ticket to dinner oh
my God can you look at the fine print
does it say like you'll be with you know
yeah yeah you're it's a virtual dinner
yeah it's a zoom dinner he's eating
Kentucky Fried Chicken on his plane
right you know and I like how you're
you're going to be in an exclusive club
and they show like a helicopter but
meanwhile you just have an email with a
photo in it this is my helicopter it's
the best helicopter
no one's had a better helicopter better
than Lincoln's Lincoln didn't have a
helicopter
look at that stupid [ __ ] horse why
yeah why did he also say that better
than Lincoln better that definitely
better than Washington listen man he's
leaning all in he's going full pro
wrestling uh half of me wants to see
that happen again it's going down yes
unless they put him in jail it's going
to happen and it looks like Biden's
gonna run against him this they've been
saying doesn't say much it's crazy when
and where is this oh it's Mar-A-Lago
cocktail hour the location will be at
one hour they [ __ ] gun everyone in
the room down
we will give you at least 30 days notice
to plan your trip all costs and expenses
associated with Live Events made
available to digital trading cards
owners including but not limited to all
federal state and local taxes Aaron
ground transportation activities Airline
luggage Black Tie is optional
optional you can wear a red tie it'll be
in South Florida south Florida we'll
give you at least 30 days notice to plan
your trip all costs and expenses
associated with the live event
but not limited to oh so they pay for
everything they fly you in they pay for
everything you have to tip anybody you
get upgrades does it say that
all cost and expensive but not limited
to
fail the two but not limited to all
federal yeah I think they pay all your
taxes on the sole and exclusive
responsibility of those that attend the
gala wait
hold on hold on travel expenses are the
sole and exclusive responsibility of
those that attend oh so there's a misc
miscellaneous I say I confuse the period
in miscellaneous because they didn't say
miscellaneous they just said misc with a
period at the end of it okay let's read
that again it says all costs and
expenses associated with the live event
made available to digital Trading Card
owners including but not limited to all
federal and state local taxes air and
ground transportation gratuities Airline
luggage charges incidentals upgrades
Insurance service charge and other
miscellaneous travel expenses are the
sole and exclusive responsibility of
those that attend the gallon dinner so
it's the opposite of what I thought it
was it's everyone you have to pay for
everything yeah
yeah so you have to pay taxes you have
to pay for your transportation you have
to pay for tips Airline luggage
incidentals upgrade everything Insurance
okay when is the zoom call how do we get
involved
you know he's got regular size hands
does he oh yeah shook his hand really he
came to the UFC uh he was behind us and
uh came up to us put his hand on my
shoulder and I looked up and it's
[ __ ] Donald Trump and I just put my
head up and I think this is nice to meet
you shook his hand regular [ __ ] hand
yeah and he put his hands on Daniel
Corman he's like I would not want to
fight this guy
would not want to fight this guy and
Daniel's like holy [ __ ] it's 45.
45 and 47. it's look I know he's a
threat to democracy there's a lot of
threats folks there's a lot wrong here
it's not just that guy but if you deny
the humor of what that guy is well
you're laughing at him you are opening
the door to chaos but all right it's
still funny you're not gonna stop people
from laughing at that so you can't do
that you can't stop people from
recognizing how [ __ ] insane it is to
have an actual former president be on TV
selling like digital cartoons of himself
saying they're the greatest they're so
inexpensive for what you get
I'm the best president better than
Lincoln I'm your favorite look at these
things he's a he's a hunter who's built
like the rock with a with a gun these
are crazy
these are so funny Superman yeah look at
the Superman one super jacked imagine if
he got a trainer and started getting
jacked
the art style looks awesome by the way
it almost looks like AI but it also
looks like he just got a fiver like you
know that website Fiverr he just paid
somebody five bucks to make a
it's perfect it'll look good over the
kitchen table everybody has to say their
prayers and then look to Trump for
guidance
before every meal
look at him